cast away your childish there your
mother bury your father tell me who you
are
I'm tired
Danny Ryan comes back to New York after
being gone for 15 years after building
those white shoes he believes it he'll
be received with open arms
I'm Danny Rand gonna wear a long time
the first thing you realize is that the
world's changed Ward joy his childhood
friend joy and Ward's an hour
billionaires from his father's
corporation sorry but I'm calling
security
oh wait no it's me they don't believe at
em to begin with standing room dead but
what don't do this Danny just want to do
the right thing but he has this fire in
him
Oh
where'd you drain can't really get there
committee
we find out he spent 15 years in a
monastery training to become this
warrior how you got that tattoo
not exactly a tattoo its market the
artist the force that runs through the
universe the fire of the fit and Danny
cannon ignites it
Danny has been told his whole life that
there's a mythological dark force in the
world and he didn't really believe that
they were real or they are very real
it's infected Rand all these people have
their own agendas
even though who's good and who's bad
there will always be forces gathering
against killed disguised as a friend
having passed you as a stranger they are
everywhere you know who the good guys
going to be it's really fun to go on
that journey with the character embrace
your destiny the show just hits you full
throttle
if he is no place for the iron I have a
vision of total victory and nothing
happens
[Music]
hi I'm Danny ran in a way a long time
let's go below here I'm Danny Rand
welcome I left here 10 years old and a
jet my parents I became the lone
survivor Danny Rand
back from the dead why didn't wait at
least lung tissue how the hell did he
learn martial arts
Reggie dream come on
my father instilled in me a love and
respect for this company that has never
faced this is my home
brand is my company this city is no
place for daddy
we've given up no pyramid or many what
happened to you why are you really hot
here some bad people have gone on the
inside
criminals I know what they are they can
do the sizer we need someone with
special skills I've been training my
whole life
[Music]
I'm going with you or not you need the
change is coming down become what you
were meant to be
I am the iron sense how does that mean
you
you